[Applaudissements]
roberdam désolé avec moi j'ai tout gâché
[Musique]
she him as tué mon bar vraiment content
tu vas bonjour je suis un merci de venir
tant d'amour ont fait huit enfants
oui bien tout tu t'écrases toujours
toujours que tu peux faire ton télé ça
détend on peut faire des appels ou faire
également des consultations davantage
question peut faire tu peux faire des
trucs et des cadets quoi donner pourquoi
avec les cages et consultations pour les
seconds
mais sur quoi j'aurais sans quoi le
décolleté
[Musique]
et bien j'espère mon corps et j'ai même
un qui n'avait les huit un petit peu
avec la leopard alerte
non mais j'en suis si j'ai attaqué quand
ça marche
4-4 a compris ça cartonne et ça te plaît
et bien voilà il faut qu'on monte un peu
sur les jeunes et sur ses sus
après il faut ni ménagères ménagères bon
ça va très bien montée vous l'apport de
3 tu vois on est un peu c'est normal ça
va monter petit à petit mais chemin qui
mènera les traits de mémoire je sais
plus comment vous avez fait là j'ai pas
vu qu est-ce que ma question pourquoi ce
qu'ils feront tout ce qui est rare est
cher il regarde moi je t'en supplie
c'est
[Musique]
retourne toi
tamera d'autres regardent mais la bible
gare est super gars mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la gamme dark à pékin mais [ __ ] mais
vous êtes des tarés
[Applaudissements]